[Music]
robert dubois
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with the kryptonite bullet i'm
not joining your suicide squad
we'll see my court date is coming up
and miss wallace and maybe you could
help me out you're flinching in my door
everyone stand down this wall stand down
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in or out
good let's meet your team it's okay i'm
not okay
each member is chosen for his or her own
completely unique set of abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late i had to go
number two good to know
is this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think of this mate i'm gonna
go with afghan hound
oh my god is it a werewolf yo they sent
me next to a weirdo
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel he's harmless
i mean he's not harmless he's killed 27
children but you know
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known only
as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
stay off the calm